there's a wealth of hidden treasures in
Mamma Mia - for fans to enjoy with
little connections nods and winks to
costumes choreography music jokes and
more from the first film
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal
ten amazing details you may have missed
in the mummy a sequel which will make
you love it even more the special
connection between Donner and Sophie and
the symmetry between the two characters
are at the heart of here we go again for
example there's a delightful link back
to young Donna silver butterfly necklace
in the christening scene where sophie
was a dress with a butterfly pattern the
film's costume designer chose that
particular design as the idea was that
Sophie was wearing the dress in memory
of her mother
the horseshoe necklace that sophie was
in the sequel is also a sweet and subtle
link back to her mother and how her
experience on the island changed her
life the first night that young Donna
stayed in the old farmhouse on the hill
there was a big storm which frightened a
horse in the stables taking care of that
skirt horse not only brought a young
salmon to Donna's life but also
ultimately led her to open the hotel
that's because Sophia who owned the
building believed you could judge a
person by the way they treat animals and
the fact that Donna was so kind -
Sophia's horse Hector led her to offer
the old farmhouse to Donna to live in
for free if she did it up remember Phil
and Sophie's conversation in the first
film after he realized he might be her
father you know it comes next
you're not going to tell me that you
have a twin sister well here we go again
gives an amusing explanation for Bill's
reaction in the original film as we find
out in the sequel bill himself has a
twin brother who pretends to be bill at
a prestigious awards ceremony so the
real bill can go to the opening party
for Sophie's hotel on the same night
when young Donna gets chased by a goat
during the name of the game scene it
feels like a little nod back to the
first film when Meryl Streep's Donna was
surprised by a goat while singing Mamma
Mia in the original film Sam Harry and
Bill stayed in the old goat house when
Sophie tried to hide them from her
mother when they first arrived on the
island and I also wonder whether the
really amusing story about a goat that
Bill's twin brother wanted to tell at
the awards ceremony had anything to do
with the goats of Sophia's old farmhouse
remember that Sofia was actually Bill
and his
there's great arms I've named after
Sophia I used to have a great aunt
living on the mainland named Sophia a
crucial piece of Donna's wardrobe in the
first movie was her denim dungarees and
the sequence shows their origin but even
before young Donna purchases her
signature outfit in the new film the
costume department cleverly leaves a
trail for that moment dressing Lily
James in denim shorts in bikini blue
tops denim jackets and later in the film
denim fleurs and the dynamos when I
kissed the teacher outfits also have an
interesting origin if you look really
closely in Donna's student room in
Oxford you'll notice is some material
missing from the brown yellow and cream
striped curtains the idea was to hint at
the inventiveness of Donna Tania and
Rosie who made their outfits themselves
out of those very curtains the concept
for the dynamos cutout curtain clothes
was inspired by movies such as Gone with
the Wind The Sound of Music and
enchanted and costume designer Michelle
Clapton added stuck on stars and fake
fur Boas to enhance the 70s vibe here we
go again features some really fun
callbacks to the choreography in the
first film for example at the very end
of the dance routine for when I kissed
the teacher the frame freezes on young
Donna as she's about to dive bomb into
the river just as we saw Meryl Streep's
Donna do at the end of dancing Queen in
the first film though Streep did
actually jump in according to writer
director ole Parker the reason we don't
get to see the dynamos jump into the
water is that it would have held up
filming as the actresses would have got
soaked and needed lots of time to fix
their hair and clothes again for each
take so instead they jumped onto a crash
pad that's out a shot and there's
another cool callback during the dance
routine for why did it have to be me
when young Donna pinches bills hat and
pops it on her own head just like Meryl
Streep's Donna did to the ship's captain
during her performance of many many many
in the original film it was really
beautiful how Meryl Streep and Amanda
cipher its choreography during my love
my life mirrored their performance
during slipping through my fingers in
the first film each scene takes place at
a very emotional point in the story
Donna Singh slipping through my fingers
as she helped so if you get ready for
her wedding and the way they stand
together here coincides with the song's
lyrics sometimes I wish that I could
freeze the picture and save it from
funny tricks of time number mere to
cause back to that image of them in
front of the mirror when Donna makes her
first appearance reflected in the
chapels baptismal font and as they join
together singing my love my life the
lyrics they sing like reflections of
your mind feel especially fitting
there's a lovely bit of musical symmetry
between the sequal and the first film in
the original movie after the curtain
core performance of waterloo amanda
seyfried version of thank you for the
music plays over the closing credits and
the sequel mirrors this of ciphered
again sings thank you for the music this
time as sophie writes invitations for
the hotel's opening party and there's
another delightful musical connection
between the beginning of each film in
the sequel when Sophie tells Cienfuegos
that she needs him to make sure the
place is ready for the party rather than
post the invites he replies whatever you
dream miss Sophie will make reel which
is a nice link back to the original
movie which began and ended with Sophie
singing I have a dream first as she
posted letters to her three potential
fathers and later she left her dad's a
mum behind on the island to travel with
her boyfriend Skye now if you want to
know some important changes Mamma Mia -
may - the original story tap in the top
right - check out that video and let me
know in the comments which moments you
loved most in here we go again and any
other details or connections you spotted
between the two movies for a chance to
win one of these awesome Mamma Mia -
merch packs make sure you subscribe
leave me a comment about the film and
also tap the gleam link in the video
description below to register your entry
tap left to watch my full Mamma Mia and
musicals playlist or tap right for
another video you're sure to like if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate a
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers